ton corps n'est qu'une enveloppe
j'ai tant d'effets comme un serpent kits
famille
c'est la conscience humaine harry va se
transférer entre plusieurs corps
pour l'éternité combien de temps j'ai
été stockées 250 ans
vous êtes la propriété de lawrence
bancroft ils t'ont score
il est équipé d'un orage un militaire et
d'une musculature mémoire de combat
monsieur coatch je ne vous ai jamais
demandé de me ramener
ce que je vous demande c'est d'élucider
un meurtre celui de qui le mien vous
avez quand même
celui qui a assassiné lors elle doit
être retrouvé sinon nous sommes tous en
danger
j'ai besoin d'infos que vous refusez de
me communiquer
et je vais trouver des réponses qui
selon vous ne regarde pas
les amis les ennemis les employés et
tous ceux qui avaient un mobile
aucune confiance en elle
notre enquête s'éternisait je devrai
simplement les fesses je te voyais plus
grands ils m'ont forcé à prendre des
renforts c'était grossier
qui compte des parce que tu veux bien
voir
le mystère qu'on doit absolument
résoudre
au lieutenant mon boulot c'est pas
seulement de vous sauver les fesses
j'aime bien